somebody driving into town the first
time you wouldn't think there was a lot
here because 95% of it is hiding
underground people drive in and go where
is the place I don't understand Cuba PT
is from the aboriginal a pickie which
means white man and a whole at the
moment upstairs
it is about 122 degrees Fahrenheit down
here we're sitting on about 71 72
degrees no air conditioning necessary
well right out in the middle of nowhere
it takes a day to drive here from
Adelaide I'd say there's about a
thousand underground dwellings and at
least 1500 people living on the ground
we've got five underground churches
we've got underground motels there's
some amazing underground homes here many
bedrooms underground workshop
you name it underground we've pretty
well got it I bought my dog out as a
fairly small two-bedroom dog out and
I've been extending it over the years
some of this side blasted out where I
could get away with it the cops don't
life is blasting intent we don't do it
anymore
back in the old days if somebody was
going to have a baby
we'd rock around there with a couple of
compressors on the weekend and some
jackhammers on the couple of cartons of
beer and by the Sunday night we dug out
a room cemented the floor and wired it
up and there's your new baby's room
honey even though we're so far away
geographically from anywhere else but I
know why but we just loved the place to
piss